thank you
great
so now we open the powerful people to
ask the speakers questions i guess pong
needs a
microphone yeah
we can share mine also i can that's true
i can just hand it to you and yeah but
also yeah we're going to share the
microphone
do you want us to share the microphone
okay that's enough thank you yeah we
just here okay
so
any questions for any of the speakers
thanks um i have a question about the
missingness indicator method
you mentioned that it is not appropriate
for observational settings
could you give us a sketch of why and
is it just that there are much stronger
assumptions needed or is there a
fundamental sense in which it's not
appropriate
yeah oh this is a
that's a good question so in
observational studies it depends on what
assumption i want to impose for example
there are two ways
uh one way is to assume the standard
unconfoundedness
treatment independent of potential
outcomes
even the idea of the period but here
also there is a missing
there is another way to impose
assumption
as uh treatment independent of potential
outcomes given the observed coherence
and the missing pattern this is in the
rosamond
maybe it's better under this under the
second setting
conditioning and the observed covariates
and the business only the observable
part of the covariance and
the missingness pattern
it may work
of course i learned some molecules
further
there were simulation studies in the
epidemiology showing didn't work
and our own critique on the second
assumption is it's not very
scientific because
it says
for
different
business method
the compounders are different so the
second assumption is a little weird
scientifically
uh can you hear me okay
uh so this question is regarding the
gene association studies or multiple
populations
so as i understand the problem you want
to associate y with x using some
relation that more or less remains
invariant across multiple populations
right
so in machine learning there's been some
recent interest on learning
invariant predictors table predictors
there has been a lot of proposals so i
was just wondering
if any of them would be suitable for
your task the second thing second
question related question i would like
to ask is you emphasized a lot on fdr
control and being able to
have a procedure for false discovery
rate control
but usually these machine learning
approaches so far do not have any such
right guarantees like in the knockoff
regime right
for the lasso problem so i was just
wondering
whether you've looked at any of these
other things and how crucial is this fdr
controlled by your problem
thank you
so the fdr could let me start from the
bottom
the fdr control is
necessary um
to gain traction in the genetics
community so
um
geneticists have been playing with
statistical ideas for a very long time
it's a field
that has experienced in the last 20
years an increase in throughput
but it's a very different field from
molecular biology in that you know when
we started having a lot of data in
molecular biologists 20 years ago
molecular biologists really
had not been used to use statistics and
geneticists instead have always
been thinking about their problem
hand-in-hand with statisticians the
founding fathers of the disciplines are
shared you know people like fischer and
so on
so one thing that geneticists have
always been very aware of is that when
you look through the genome to
identifying a location that it's
important for a trade you have a big
problem of look everywhere effect you
have a big problem of multiple
comparisons
they started out in a setting where they
actually could measure very few things
just like
blood groups for example and so their
presumption was well if i see an
association between blood group and a
trait i have to be very careful thinking
about is it true or not because the
chances that this trait and blood group
sit really close together in the genome
is very small because the genome is very
big
and now moving on to the air
the co-current era where we
can assess genomic variation across the
entire genome at millions of locations
they are still very concerned about this
if i see an association i want to be
really sure that this is true that it's
not simply because i have many
possibilities to look for so in fact
the standard in the field it's
controlling family-wise error right
which is a little bit of an overkill for
problems like the one i'm interested in
which are complex traits so traits that
by definition
are influenced by very many locations in
the genome so if you are hunting for say
a hundred or thousands of variants that
might be important for the trade it
really doesn't make any different to you
if you make one false discovery or not
so the family-wise error rate is really
an overkill and it's totally meaningful
to do false discovery rate control but
to abandon any form of multiplicity
control it really would be perceived in
the genetic field as
then we cannot trust your results at all
and rightly so you know we hear a lot
about reclusive diabetes crisis in
science that's not something that has
been concerning in genetics what have
been identified as hit in genome-wide
association study tend to be highly
reproducible and they are not going to
give up this attainment stage in time
now
you are absolutely right that machine
learning in general has become very
interest in robust and invariant type of
predictions and i think very rightly so
i do think that if we want to have
predictive models that we can deploy
we need to have
robustness guarantees that
and i think all of these models are
interesting for this problem
i haven't studied
and tried out many
um but you know um
the
going back to this fdr control these
knock off methods are designed to work
with any machine learning algorithm so
um
we actually um
have tried to play a little bit with
dominic
uh one of dominic's method and
wrap around it the uh
norcos algorithm to see if we can
achieve fdr control while
we meet from the get go looking for
invariant effects so but that's a
direction that can be explored much
any further questions
so
i mean
the randomization
does it enter in in some sense knockoff
it's kind of form of
negative control and with some
randomization kind of in there
and then in jennifer's work
do you think there's necessity to go
into
small
inference less uncertainty
quantification in the design like oh you
just do
kind of the next level i think the
uncertainty
goes into the predictive model that
you're leveraging to do the design and
that is something that slides into i
support my students quarterbacks with
mike uh has just put out a paper on it's
like sending conformal prediction to the
case where of like active learning where
the test set depends on the training
center
and how we think about uncertainty there
i don't think that works
uh yeah we have to think about how that
directly is applicable to some of the
kind of on-the-ground stuff
we're doing but i do think that
that's very important to understand
i think it's kind of relevant there too
right
um
um
it's been a long time since i thought
about false discovery i always think of
pulse discovery rate is uh giving me
like
uh like practically for the problems i
care about it's giving me like a
threshold above which maybe my
experimenter might want to go look for
some way to think about that threshold
so if my collaborator wants to no matter
what measure 100 things then i just need
to rank order
um but if he or she wants to know
whether it's worth it to do those other
things then i guess some fdr might be
useful
or it could also just be unfold about
the same one right i think in the
neuroscience that's what people have
been doing like where to cut out but i
think in general the post mascara is a
modern concept it's like whatever the
experiments you do
you want the yield to be high right so
yeah i guess if you're doing active
learning like like i don't know how you
think about str for active learning
because it's not really a notion of like
kids it's a notion of exploration versus
exploitation right and helping to figure
out how to learn the landscape and then
maybe once you feel like you've learned
it then maybe the fbr kicks in
and also the range could be different
you can be a lot more relaxed and
control with five percent
yes
explorations you can change this ratio
it could be interesting
i mentioned the missing
pattern method and
demonstrated that using a synthetic
analysis that the missing pattern method
is
better has better efficiency and
but you also caution a guest against
using that in practice so i wonder can
you provide a finite simple
characterization analysis of the of
these um different types of methods and
then so the finite sample analysis can
provide better guidance in terms of how
to use which
one in practice
oh yeah i think that's a more difficult
question
in theory like deriving the finite
example
on those estimators and even if we
derive those things usually it depends
on a lot of our known constants so i'm
not sure whether
the theory can give us guidance but i
think it's a
the gap between theory and practice
really improve
asymptotics and then look at the finite
data you know you say okay
do we trust the theory or not
yeah i think that's a good question but
it's very difficult to answer using
theory
so i'm going to ask a very similar
question here um
which is that
i guess you'd given us an asymptotic or
ordering in terms of the efficiency
and the asymptotic so you know we're
working in a finite population
model where
asymptotic doesn't mean draw more
samples asymptotic means
i have a new pop population i have a
sequence of populations and i put
conditions on
how the sequence is
and
you know i guess with that ordering i
wanted to clarify and kind of ask a
question
i guess the thing i wanted to clarify as
i was looking at it i think well
you know
the to make that ordering true i guess
we have to have an asymptotic
uh sequence where the most
uh complicated ass ask me where is like
the missingness of like all pairs and
that kind of stuff and
higher order missingness
we have to see enough of the higher
order missingness in our asymptotic to
make that good whereas you know if i had
a weaker asymptotic you know see
sequence um
where i said oh you'll just you'll never
observe a lot of pairs or a lot of
higher order but you still observe
missingness for the single order then
you know the estimator that you do say i
think we'll perform better because the
other one we can't prove anything about
so all that to say is i was looking at
this ordering and i guess my thought was
there's no like one true asymptotic or
ordering like under different asymptotic
sequences
the more complicating might be worse
under more conservative ones
are under more stringent stronger
conditions
the more complicated one performs the
best and i think that seemed to capture
a lot of like the
you know
which one do we
recommend if we're doing asymptotic
analyses comes down to
which asymptotic sequence do i believe
in
more and i guess i was hoping
one to see if i'm on the right page of
this or if i've missed a crucial step
but also how you think about
you know this this fact that comes up
particularly in finite population
where it's just it's as i've branded
this fact too it's a very difficult
thing
um
to interpret the asymptotics how do you
how do you think about that when we get
to choose the conditions on our
asymptotics
yeah i think that's a very good question
so here we focus on the design-based
theory so we'll focus on the finite
population energy effect but at the same
time
we also talk about asymptotics saying
the sample size grow grows to infinity
like the people after that saying okay
you are using two contradictory words
for the same problem
but that's a uh
in some sense it's a challenge for
frequent test
statistics but we have a finite data set
we say oh we embed this finite message
into a sequence hypothetically then
sequence grow then we have some
probability
properties for them sequence
rather than proper those properties
tell us something about the final data
we have
we have to make a
make a decision maybe based on other
things like what which sequences is good
for us like
which sequence
match reality either in some sense it's
beyond the data i think we need some
other
items
yeah
we're we're talking about this issue
in our have another reading course
foundations of
statistics like we always face this
challenge even under statistics theory
from financial infinite
deeply
you can you can say this is relative the
problem of
induction like star and data points you
want to say something beyond with some
data points
frequently solution is
hypothetical sequence
right so if a question for the third
speaker
so you were talking about looking um
your problem is roughly speaking you
want to search over a huge discrete
space and you said that in practice
people have some good ideas of what are
the good starting points for this
directed evolution
may i know like this is is this like
some domain knowledge and how accurate
is this starting points what what what
happens if the starting point is focused
or yeah there's a def i mean it is
domain knowledge of different levels so
like one level is just
like an actual protein that you already
know exists like for some
reason i guess so that's quite common
and then other forms of domain knowledge
come in
in terms of for example how to induce
variation in the population so i didn't
talk about it but
uh instead of just randomly
um
making changes from a parent to get a
population something you do instead is
you actually make like blocks contiguous
blocks and then you change around the
blocks from the different variants like
like kind of interchangeably and there's
a question of like where can i put a
break point in the protein that's going
to induce useful variation where useful
means doesn't like collapse
uh so it still functions and moreover
the function i care about is you know
has some variability and so there people
bring in domain knowledge from the like
structure for example as deduced by a
crystal structure or alpha fold
um so
so there is quite a lot of domain
knowledge the other kind of domain
knowledge that comes in is just through
very long decades of research people may
know that i can change these four
positions on this protein and that's
just useful for the same kinds of
reasons
um
so some of the domain knowledge is just
the actual protein you start with and
sometimes it's a set of parents where
you then play like lego blocks a bit
sometimes it's a single one but it is
all
typically from
like many years of work that have
revealed domain knowledge
so there is a different version of
protein engineering i didn't talk about
but you've probably you may have heard
of david baker's lab at the university
of washington which does biophysics
based modeling of course now also with
machine learning but uh it took a really
long time before they agreed to go there
and uh and they're kind of arguing
for more what is called de novo design
which i hesitate to use because i don't
think it was ever super well defined and
i think it's really not well defined now
but the idea there is to say i don't
really know a starting point i'm just
interested in can i make proteins that
look nothing like existing proteins but
still stably fold
and not even necessarily for a
particular purpose and so in that case
there's still reliance on
say core lego blocks that exist in all
proteins that we call like the secondary
structure you may have seen pictures
with these loops these like alpha
helices or these beta sheets so there's
some sort of quite core components and
using so they're still using domain
knowledge but ultimately it's more
biophysics uh driven
uh as well
thank you
i have a follow-up question on that so
you mentioned the piece x giving cedar
what form is actually
yeah so i mean we never did any great
due diligence on that we were using
variational auto encoders
um
and
it's not something we ended up exploring
very much for the particular
aav gene therapy collaboration in that
case we used the distribution permitted
by the control knobs which was this very
simple
uh marginal distribution over the amino
acids at each position
because that's all they could control so
you didn't really go for some
non-parametric forms like from
autoencoder just
in the algorithm you get the form for
the
pc there
because you're optimizing over p
exceeded right yeah or sata yeah did you
ever write down an analytical phone for
that well oh i mean do you call the
variational auto encoder analytical
alcohol algorithmic
uh
i mean we
mostly we played either with variational
autoencoders or with the particular
distribution that we were allowed to um
give back to the lab uh i know that at
some point i knew some people at google
that we're trying to explore more
systematically what might be a good
model for that there's and there's a
separate there's so many interacting
parts here but
i mean something i didn't mention is
that when you're trying to learn this
predictive model that goes from sequence
to a scalar property of interest i i
mentioned it as though it's primarily
from labeled paired data but actually
there's a a
huge dependence in many cases not in our
example but on using actually
evolutionarily related data that are not
strictly speaking coming with a label so
and then you build a density model
from a set of proteins and you interpret
the evaluation of the density as the
fitness
and uh and then there's a large body of
literature there asking what are good
suitable model classes to do that and
why are they good
um and this kind of thing but that's a
slightly different problem because
that's saying i want to model a set of
proteins that i think are related
evolutionarily and capture their density
well whereas we're using it as like a
mechanism as part of the design process
and you might ask like how are those
similar and how are those different i
think i think is actually an interesting
question
uh i have a question um for the
genome association study
um although the look of master seems to
control the fdr
it seems to make much fewer discoveries
so
my first question is is this because on
these discoveries are far apart like in
the genome space whereas the chivas
discoveries are more concentrated among
each other um and and or is this because
um the knock of method is based on
conditional independence whereas the
trios is based on just the independent
test um and the second question is like
if so like how do we make the trade-offs
among the total number of discoveries
the fdr rate and the total number of
populations to consider
the multi-environment factors
[Music]
fewer discoveries
because it insists these discoveries to
be consistent not possible to pull it
back
what happens there is that you have one
environment with many observations so
it's easy to make a discovery there it's
very difficult to reject the nodes in
the other violence so you have a drop of
power
to insist it has to be in at least two
environments it's just very difficult to
do that
so
it has um it's not the conditional
hypothesis that it's a problem in fact
it compares the methods i showed you are
all testing conditional analysis
so what what's happening in general when
you insist the discovery to be true
multiple environments you're going to
have higher time making those and in the
particular data set that i showed you is
really not the power to make discoveries
um
i
also want to make another point about
fdr control that was connected to what
was raised before
uh so jennifer says oh it doesn't really
matter it's a question or back in my
results and then my collaborator my
tests as many as they want
that's certainly true in some sense it's
not true in a
gene
people do not know how to test if an
association is important
i mean they know in theory but say to
prove
that some gene influences your risk of
developing schizophrenia it's very hard
to do experimentally
you don't modify embryos you see if they
develop secretly or not so you have to
go to an individual system and how do
you measure schizophrenia you know you
can use house models
so
there is that thing to keep in mind
um that not
not all of the type of experiments that
we do can be handed on to somebody else
to verify the discovery
you know effective passion quickly
i think it's also a question of being
able to know
to describe to the world what is it that
we know you know we do science we make
these discoveries and yes there is a
order among them but
it's important for us to be able to
communicate to the public we believe
that this is really true or not even if
we don't have
at the moment let's make it with the
possibility to
be tested in a hundred different sets
did i answer your question yes yes
i just want to say i completely agree
and i used to work in statistical
genetics and my comment was restricted
soul mate solely to i just yeah to be
clear yeah i completely agree
yeah so one other way to do it is you
have i understand that one cannot verify
experimentally whether an association is
true or not so i get the point so not
quite yet but then
um putting on my machine learning hack i
would say
well if i have access to data from six
populations i'll withhold the sixth one
right i'll try to do
some invariant prediction of whatever
algorithm i have without any fdr
procedure
uh on the five of them and then try to
see if it holds
in some sense on the sixth
right
and uh i would if it just works for any
one hold out i would just leave one hold
out and i would just say this is this is
a good
uh and this is a good model right
without making any statement about how
much false discovery i have so that's
that's one question i uh i had in mind
the second thing is
if you go into knockoff filters
right
they do assume
that you have the ability to generate
the conditional distribution of xj given
x minus j
i understand that in genetics maybe the
gaussian model is
well well known to work very well if
that's the case probably that's a good
thing to
i mean that's a great thing but in
general if i want to do this knock off
fdr control over arbitrary distributions
and non-parametric associations
the main difficulty is to verify this
conditional sampling assumption
and
you i mean you are just offloading the
problem somewhere else so your fdr
guarantee is not exactly an fdr
guarantee because it's conditional on
having this conditional sampler i know
there have been works that actually deal
with this problem and all that but i
just wanted to say uh the fdr also has
one subtext so yeah
yeah
there's never any free lunch thank you
um
but so
for sure you can say i i build the model
and then i test it in another population
um
and in some sense that's what people do
even what i did that in the last
pic table i have okay this is my results
and this is how many of these have
external validation right
i don't think that however if you're
building the model and testing how it
works in another population in terms of
does it have predictive power
it's it's not terribly useful to have
these um
test errors to measure how well you
selected your value i think the the
evidence that we have accumulated so far
it's really that it's quite difficult to
estimate test error to start with and
it's not terribly easy to backtrack
from the test error to the validity of
the variable selections now
to construct knockoff you need to know
at least the knockoffs i mentioned here
you need to know the distribution of the
predictor variables and that it's a big
assumption
you know at some point i insisted you
don't have to make any assumption on how
the trait depends on the genetic
variants but what we're making
assumption is that we know the
distribution of the genetic values
so it depends your eye that depends in
the context where you are at in genetics
i think to make the assumption that we
know the distribution of the genetic
variants is really not a crazy
assumption we have a lot of data sets
that have been collected on genotypes in
many populations we can use them to fit
models for the genetic variant and
incidentally we don't use gaussian
approximations typically we have models
that are hidden markov models that are
accepted in genetics for other reasons
but there you have a variety of tools in
some other data sets you might not have
really the abundance of observations on
x's to fit proper distributions
now there are as you mentioned there are
some works that uh
look at this problem in more general
setups with uh
adversarial networks and so you can do
these deep knockoffs if you have enough
data even if you have no prior knowledge
on what the distribution is you can try
to fit it but that is definitely one
uh reality you have to confront yourself
to do you have enough data on the x's or
knowledge to um
input there to know what their
distribution is it's also true that if
you're looking at your data
with
models that are fairly simple like the
last one
in fact all what you need to map to
match are the variance covariance
structures so even if so if if you want
to say i
lash i
let out you use every possible machine
learning tool then you really have to
have knockoff that completely match
in distribution your original variable
and
cross exchangeability but if you are
using simple tools like rasu really the
second order moment is all what matters
so it makes it much easier
well um
i think this is a great discussion and
let's carry it over to lunch
and let's send
free speaker for survival box
i will come back at 2 for another
session 3 speakers